the mom museum partnering with local law
enforcement and local agencies to host a
free virtual safety forum series
some of the topics include unemployment
fraud domestic violence among many
others
tonight's topic was election integrity
the virtual forum addressed concerns
about the security and
integrity of the upcoming general
election
the voting equipment that we use in the
state undergoes
rigorous testing and auditing both
before an election and after an election
uh to make sure that it's functioning
correctly
all the equipment has to be certified
for use
the fbi and the rest of the members of
the election integrity task force
really are reliant upon the public
that when they see something that
doesn't seem right to them
just like we ask on other criminal
matters but if something doesn't seem
right to them
to please report it right away for more
information about the election you can
visit the nevada secretary of state
website
that's nvsos.gov the fbi has a website
to report any federal election offense
as well
that's tips.fbi.gov we have more
information on both of these websites on
our website
8newsnow.com